so what i have here is an expression
where i'm multiplying rational
expressions and we want to do this
multiplication and then reduce the
lowest term so if you feel so inspired i
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can have a go at that
all right now let's work through this
together
so multiplying rational expressions like
this it's very analogous to multiplying
fractions for example if i were to
multiply
six
twenty-fifths
times
fifteen
over nine
there's a few ways you could do it you
could just multiply six times fifteen in
the numerator and twenty-five times nine
in the denominator but the way that many
of us approach it so that it's easier to
reduce to lowest terms is to factor
things to realize that look six is two
times three
nine is three times three
fifteen is 3 times 5 and 25 is 5 times 5
and then you can realize in your
eventual product you're going to have a
5 in the numerator 5 in the denominator
you can 5 divided by 5 is 1 3 divided by
3 is 1 and then 3 divided by 3 is 1. and
so all you'd be left with is that 2 and
then that 5. so this is going to be
equal to two-fifths so we'll do the
analogous thing here with these rational
expressions we're going to factor them
all of them in the numerators and the
denominators and then we'll see if we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator by the same thing now the
one thing we have to make sure of as we
do that is we keep track of the domain
because these rational expressions here
they might have x values that make their
denominators equal to zero
and so even if we reduce to lowest terms
and we get rid of those expressions in
order for the expressions to be the same
expression we have to constrain the
domain in the same way
so let's get started
so this is going to be equal to i'll
just rewrite everything x squared minus
nine how do we factor that well that's
going to be a difference of squares we
could write that as x plus 3
times x minus 3
and then that is going to be over
this business and let's see 5 squared is
25 negative 5 plus negative 5 is
negative 10. so this is going to be x
minus
5
times x minus 5. if what i'm just doing
here with the factoring is not making
sense i encourage you to review
factoring on khan academy and then we
multiply that
times let's see in this numerator here i
can factor out a 4 so that's going to be
4
times x minus 5 which is going to be
useful i have an x minus 5 there x minus
5 there and then that's going to be over
let's see
this expression over here
2 plus 3 is 5 2 times 3 is 6. so it's
going to be x
plus 2
times x
plus 3. now before i start reducing to
lowest terms let's think about the
domain here and the domain is going to
be constrained by things that make these
denominators equal to 0.
so the domain would be all real numbers
except x cannot equal five let me write
it over here x cannot equal
five because if that happened then this
denominator would be equal to zero x
cannot be equal to negative two
x could not be equal to negative 2
because that would make the denominator
here zero which would make the
denominator here zero and x cannot be
equal to
negative three so the domain is
constrained in this way we have to carry
this throughout no matter what we do to
the expression this is the constraints
on our domain
with that out of the way now we can
reduce to lowest terms
so
x we have an x plus 3 in the numerator x
plus 3 in the denominator x minus 5 in
the numerator x minus 5 in the
denominator and i think we've gone about
as far as we can and so when we multiply
the numerators we are going to get this
business is going to be 4 times x minus
3
4
times
x minus 3
over
we have an x minus 5 here
x
minus 5 and then we have an x plus 2.
we have an x plus 2. and we could leave
it like this if you want in some cases
people like to multiply the things out
but we're done we've just finished
multiplying these rational expressions
and we have to remind ourselves that x
cannot be equal to any of these things
now the way that we've simplified it we
still have an x minus 5 right over here
so it might be redundant to say that x
cannot be equal to 5 because that's
still the case in our reduced terms
expression here and that's true also of
the x cannot be equal to negative 2 we
still have an x plus 2 here so still
even in this expression it's pretty
clear that x cannot be equal to negative
2 but that x cannot equal negative 3
isn't so obvious when you just look at
this expression but in order for this
expression to be completely equivalent
to the original it has to have the same
domain and so you might want to
explicitly say that x cannot be equal to
negative 3 here you could also say the
other two but those are that's still
very clear when you look at this
expression